المره الاولى منذ سبعه شهور
[موسيقى]
يصل الرئيس الاوكراني الى خير سون بعد
ايام قليله من استعاده القوات الاوكرانيه
السيطره على المدينه
[موسيقى]
من المهم ان اكون هنا لدعم السكان
المحليين حتى يشعر بذلك نحن لا نتحدث فقط
ولا نعيد فقط بل نعود ونرفع رايتنا ولكن
ايضا كان انسان اود ان اعيش هذه المشاعر
هذه الطاقه من الناس محفزه للغايه
[تصفيق]
احتفالات السكان الرجل الذي يواجه القوات
الروسيه قليلا ما يتحرك خارج العاصمه تعكس
زيارته اهميه تاخير سوق كما تعكس
الاحتفالات حجم صعوبه العيش تحت ما يصفونه
بالاحتلال الروسي
الان يمكنك مشاهده احتفالات الناس وهذا
امر رائع الناس كانوا في ما يشبه السجن
يعيشون اوضاعا صعبه للغايه كل شيء سيتغير
في واحده من اهم مدننا واكثرها سعاده الان
باللغه الروسيه تعلن هذه اللوحه خير سون
روسيه الى الابد كان ذلك قبل اقل من شهرين
حين نظم الروس استفتاءا على استقلال خير
سونا عن اوكرانيا تقول موسكو ان اهالي خير
صوت هي دول الاستقلال تقول كيف انه لم
يغير من حقيقته ان خير سون اوكرانيه هذه
المره الاولى التي يصنع فيها راي عن حقيقه
ما جراحينها
في الشوارع لم يكن هناك مراكز اقتراع او
تصويت كان الامر اجباريا على الناس كثيرون
اصوت دون ان يكون معهم بطاقات الهويه او
اي وثائق الرسميه كان هناك خيار واحد في
تلك الاوراق وهو نعم للانفصال وكان
بالامكان التصويت عده مرات وكذلك التصويت
عن افراد العائله
حتى الان استعاده السيطره الاوكرانيه على
30% من مساحه المقاطعه لم يوقف تساقط
القذافي على طرفي نهر دنبرو الذي يفصل بين
الجانبين الان
يقول الاوكانيون انهم مستمرون في طريق
استعاده اراضيهم من القبضه الروسيه كذلك
قرار لا يبدو ان تنفيذه سيكون سهلا
بالنسبه لطرفي القتال خصوصا اذا ما علمنا
ان القوات الروسيه لا تبعد الا بضعه
كيلومترات من هنا بكل الاحوال يعيش
الاوكرانيون الان فرحه ما يصفونه
بالانتصار
وينتظرون المزيد
صهيب العصا الجزيره من مدينه خيرسون
جنوبيه اوكرانيا